[SINGING]
TANYARADZWA TAWENGWA:
So Umqombothi
is an African a capella group.
I founded it my freshman year.
And it was really just
motivated because I thought,
I love singing.
And I was coming from
an international school.
And I came to Princeton.
And I love the a
capella groups that
were shown at Tiger's Roar.
But I said something's missing.
We need to add
something in the mix.
A little spice.
And so Umqombothi is an
African a capella group.
[SINGING]
TOLA EMIOLA: We come in.
We figure out what songs we're
going to be performing next,
and try to go through
them, teach new members who
don't know the songs.
We teach them those songs.
And, yeah, we just basically
stand in a little arch
the whole time, and
we sing together.
[SINGING]
TOLA EMIOLA: It's a
really fun loving group.
And they have a lot of
fun when they perform.
They incorporate different
types of performance.
They dance at performance.
There's drumming.
There's just so much
heart in the group.
So I just wanted to
be a part of that.
[SINGING]
TANYARADZWA TAWENGWA:
The most beautiful thing
about Umqombothi is when
Umqombothi is not just us,
but it's a community.
And it's a community
of people, where people
come into our space and amidst
the stress and the weight
of Princeton, they
come in where there's
a performance and arch sing,
or even just a release party.
You see people shake
loose, break free,
and have a good time.
That's the ethos that
I wanted in the group.
And it's so beautiful
to see that spirit
really manifesting itself in
terms of people even outside
of the group.
I think that's the
most beautiful.